♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PROGRESSIVES
CONTINUED TO BASH ISRAEL.
JEWISH PEOPLE TARGETED FROM
COAST-TO-COAST AFTER THE RECENT
FIGHTING IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
DEMOCRATS LIKE BERNIE SANDERS
KEEP GOING AFTER ISRAEL.
SPEAK OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA HAS TO BE LEADING THE
WORLD IN BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER, NOT SIMPLY SUPPLYING
WEAPONS TO KILL CHILDREN IN
DAWES ACT.
OUR JOB IS NOT SIMPLY TO PUT
MORE MORE MILITARY SUPPORT FOR
ISRAEL, IT IS TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
>> Jesse: AFTER DAYS OF
WAITING, THEY ARE GETTING AROUND
TO CONDEMNING THE ANTI-SEMITIC
VIOLENCE.
TAKEN TO TWITTER TO CALL IT
"DESPICABLE."
DO YOU AGREE THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SUPPLYING
WEAPONS TO KILL CHILDREN IN
GAZA?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THAT
THEY ARE INTENDING TO CAUSE
VIOLENCE AGAINST CIVILIANS, BUT
I THINK THAT THAT IS THE
ARGUMENT, JESSE.
TO MY MIND, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO
BE VERY CLEAR HERE AND NOT
CONFUSE ANTI-SEMITISM WITH
LEGITIMATE CRITICISM OF DEBATE
ABOUT ISRAELI POLICIES.
THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE.
THAT'S NOT ANTI-SEMITIC TO SAY
I'D DISS TO HAVE HER WITH
ISRAEL'S POLICY IS, YOU HAVE THE
DEBATE AMONG JEWISH PEOPLE
INCLUDING BERNIE SANDERS ABOUT
WHAT ISRAEL IS DOING AND HOW IT
CONDUCTS ITS POLICIES.
YOU HAVE AIPAC VERSUS J STREET
IN TERMS OF THE JEWISH AMERICAN
COMMUNITY ARE TAKING DIFFERENT
POSITIONS, SO THERE'S NOTHING
ANTI-SEMITIC ABOUT IT IS MATT
CRITICIZING ISRAEL.
THE LARGER ISSUE IS WHERE DO WE
GO AS AN AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH
REGARDS TO THE VIOLENCE THAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE STREETS.
IT IS REPREHENSIBLE AND TO BE
CONDEMNED BY EVERY SIDE.
I DON'T CARE IF IT IS
ANTI-SOMATIC VIOLENCE AGAINST
JEWISH PEOPLE, OR ANTI-MUSLIM
VIOLENCE, ANTIWHITE, ANTIBLACK
OR THOSE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SAY
CHINESE PEOPLE BROUGHT COVID
HERE AND THEY ARE ATTACKING THE
ASIANS IN LARGER NUMBERS, ALL OF
IT TEARS AT A SET AMERICANS AND
WE NEED TO STAND TOGETHER IN
OPPOSITION OF THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR.
IN ONE LAST THING ABOUT ISRAEL,
THERE WAS A GENERATIONAL DIVIDE
AS YOU CAN START TO SEE IT NOW
ON THE POLL NUMBERS ABOUT ISRAEL
THAT DID NOT EXIST PREVIOUSLY.
EVERYBODY JUST WANTED TO SUPPORT
ISRAEL AND WERE SO VULNERABLE.
I THINK THAT ISRAEL AND THE
PRIME MINISTER AND THAT THE
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU BETTER
BE AWARE OF THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE MORE AND MORE AMERICANS WHO
ARE CRITICAL OF ISRAELI
POLICIES.
>> Jesse: I HAVE NOT SEEN
THAT, BUT YOUR POINT ABOUT
ISRAEL BEING VULNERABLE, WHY DO
YOU THINK THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ALWAYS ROOT FOR THE SO-CALLED
UNDERDOG EVEN WHEN THE UNDERDOG
IS JUST FIRING ROCKETS INTO
CIVILIAN TERRITORY?
>> Greg: THEY COULD JUST BE
STUPID, OR INCONSISTENT.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THERE IS
MORE ANTI-SEMITIC ATTACKS GOING
ON RIGHT NOW?
THERE IS A DRAMATIC UPTICK.
WHY IS THERE A RISE IN
ANTI-ASIAN ATTACKS, BECAUSE ALL
VIOLENT CRIME IS UP, RIGHT?
ALL VIOLENT CRIME IS UP ACROSS
THE BOARD.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS MONTH AGO.
IT WAS LEFT OFF, BUT YOU CANNOT
TEASE OUT SPECIFIC HATE CRIMES
AS SOMETHING REPREHENSIBLE
WITHOUT FIRST CONDEMNING ALL OF
IT AS A GROUP.
THIS IS DUE TO A REDUCTION OF
POLICING AND THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHEN YOU SEE REPEATS AND FELONS
THEY KEEP GETTING OUT NO BALE IT
SENDS A MESSAGE WHEN YOU GET
ARRESTED YOU'RE GOING TO BE OUT
ON THE STREET BEFORE THE COP IS
DONE DOING HIS PAPERWORK.
SOME PEOPLE ARE MORE IMPORTANT
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, JESSE,
TO THE MEDIA THAN OTHERS, WHICH
IS WHY THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS RESPONDED
INCONSISTENTLY TO VIOLENCE EVEN
WHEN IT IS WELL-DOCUMENTED WITH
WORDS, PICTURES, AND STATISTICS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT IS SO HARD
TO CONTAIN A CONSISTENT
DISAVOWAL OF ALL VIOLENCE.
TO THE GAIN AND THE ATTACKING OF
PEOPLE IN NEW YORK CITY.
IF WE WERE CONSISTENT, NONE OF
THE STUFF WHATEVER HAPPENED AND
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
WOULD KEEP THIS FROM HAPPENING,
BECAUSE THAT IS THE INCENTIVE
THAT ONE NEEDS.
>> Jesse: IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING THAT POLLOCK
Y
HAVE KILLED CIVILIANS.
ADMITTING THAT THEY DELIBERATELY
FIRE ROCKETS FROM CIVILIAN AREAS
IN GAZA ACTIVELY TARGETING
ISRAEL SO THAT WHEN THEY
RETALIATE THEY KILL CIVILIANS,
SO THEY ARE USED FOR PROPAGANDA.
AND WHEN YOU SEE THIS OVERFLOW
INTO THE UNITED STATES WITH
PRO-PALESTINIAN HAMAS SUPPORTING
PEOPLE ATTACKING JEWS IN THE
STREETS AND THEY KNOW THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO GET ARRESTED OR IF
THEY DO THEY WILL GET OUT REALLY
QUICKLY AND SAY IS THAT GUIDED
YESTERDAY I WOULD DO IT AGAIN
AFTER BEATING A JEWISH MAN IN
THE STREET, THEY KNOW THAT THEY
CAN GET AWAY WITH IT JUST LIKE
THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN GET AWAY
WITH ATTACKING ISRAEL BECAUSE
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY WILL
SAY, HOW DARE YOU BE VIOLENT
AGAINST HAMAS WHEN REALLY THEY
ARE JUST DEFENDING THEMSELVES,
ON AN EQUAL PLAYING FIELD WHEN
IT COMES TO EXCHANGING VIOLENCE.
>> Jesse: PRETEND YOU ARE
JEN PSAKI, DANA, I AM
PETER DOOCY.
TOMORROW I WILL SAY THE QUARTER
MILLION THAT JOE BIDEN RELATES
TO THE PALESTINIANS THAT TRUMP
FROZE, THEY PURCHASED WEAPONS
AND THEN USE THEM ON ISRAELI
CITIZENS TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REGRET RELEASING
THAT MONEY?
>> Dana: ONE THING I'VE NEVER
DONE IS FALLEN FOR A
HYPOTHETICAL, JESSE, I'M STILL
NOT GOING TO DO THAT, BUT I
WOULD KNOW ONE THING, THE FLAW
OF PROGRESSIVES INCLUDING
BERNIE SANDERS, PUTTING OUT THE
TWEETS SAYING THAT THEY CONDEMN
ANTI-SEMITISM VIOLENCE, BUT THEY
ADD TO, ALL OF THEM ADDED AND
THE RISE OF ISLAMOPHOBIA.
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT THIS, WHERE IS THE
DATA?
WHERE'S THE INQUIRY HEARD WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY SEEING IT AND I
AGREE THAT ISLAMOPHOBIA IS BAD
AND ATTACKS AGAINST PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE MUSLIM IS
TERRIBLE, BUT DO WE ACTUALLY
HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT THAT
IS HAPPENING?
THE LAST THING I WOULD POINT OUT
IS THAT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ALL REMEMBER THE
STRUGGLES WE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE NOT A MIRROR IMAGE
OF EVERY PLACE THAT WE LOOK.
AND THE ISSUES, AND KATIE KNOWS
THEM VERY WELL, WHEN YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING ON
BETWEEN THE ISRAELIS AND THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY IS MUCH
MORE NUANCED AND COMPLICATED.
IT'S NOT JUST OF BLACK AND WHITE
ISSUE, WE HAVE TO BE MORE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW WE TALK
ABOUT IT AND I WOULD SAY THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD DO MORE THAN
PUT OUT A TWEET.
TWEET MATTERS FOR A BLUE
CHECK MARK JOURNALISTS, NOT
THOSE THA